how do you prioritize your time the  meeting I had right before here was a  15-minute meeting the meeting before  that was a 15-minute meeting I get a lot  done because I believe in 15s I think  everybody in here has one hour meetings  that are actually seven minute meetings  you can imagine what ends up happening  with efficiency I have eight different  companies inside of vaynerx the holding  company and I'm the active CEO I have V  friends which is taking up an enormous  amount of time I have my family I have  my personal life I have my non-profits  the real answer is I don't judge myself  when the last week wasn't as efficient  as it could have been the number one  reason that people struggle with time  management is because they beat  themselves up for not having a  productive week day or year and they  don't realize that it's just subjective  and they're grading their own homework  and they're [ __ ] themselves up